welcome to quick take
you've said that you wrote this book for
the 20 year old version of you offering
a kind of road map for indian american
kids who don't want to be engineers or
doctors so who did you look to as a
model when you were 20 early in your
career yeah thanks carl thanks for
having me so you're right i wrote that i
wrote this book for the 20 year old
version of me which it doesn't just by
the way include other asian americans
who happen to be in their 20s but it's
really anyone in their 20s who was kind
of looking towards a career or a life
that might not be binary you know maybe
somebody who had multiple interests who
views the world outside of the lens of
things being mutually exclusive and in
my life those role models were miranaire
the film director was incredible really
looked up to denzel washington and tom
hanks um you know there were business
leaders like indra nui uh who i thought
were fantastic and and so there were
depending on when in my trajectory i
would look to folks and and and try to
look at what they've accomplished in
their lives um those are some names that
come to mind those are some pretty lofty
names one thing i did know in your uh
background is that you didn't go
completely rogue from indian family
expectations because you graduated from
an elite school you went to ucla uh you
double majored in film and sociology i
noticed that there's no econ in there so
you didn't hedge with anything practical
which is impressive was a college degree
non-negotiable with your family
well i i should point out that i did go
to ucla but i went to the theater in
film school so whatever that means to
asian americans it is a top three
program there you go
i remember being on campus in the in the
late 90s as a ucla student uh and being
shunned by other indian american
students on campus for not being a
science major
and to your point i didn't fail
statistics twice in college but yes one
of the reasons that i wanted to go to
ucla was the the more holistic approach
to learning especially as an artist was
something that was important to me you
know i i took uh pre-med classes as an
elective didn't do too well in them but
i did them because i wanted to get that
perspective on what it was like for
somebody who was going down that path in
their lives and and how to bring those
stories to life when i ultimately would
would become an actor so um i i don't
know that it's not that college was
non-negotiable it's that my great so my
gran the story is and i talk about them
in the book quite a bit my grandparents
marched with gandhi in the indian
independence movement and their views
particularly for the time period were
incredibly progressive they were very
secular they uh it was non-negotiable
that their daughters all went to not
just college but to graduate school to
the extent they were both on my mom's
side especially they were both teachers
um and so it was less a question of i
think the way that we think of it as oh
asian american parents who are part of
that post-65 group pushing their kids
towards something and it was much more
of like well grandma and grandpa who
fought for freedom literally were jailed
and beaten by british soldiers know what
the value of education is and that's why
we want you to get a higher education so
it was a little bit different outside
that framework how much support did you
have from them in experimenting and
studying theater for instance
yeah they're you know there were a
number of
there were a number of tacit support
stories that i remember um and i'm so
glad that i talked to them through
writing the book to make sure that i
kind of checked in with them and said
you know what was it like for you that
post-65 wave of asian american
immigration a lot of folks forget we
don't have to talk about that was really
to fill labor shortages in things like
medicine and engineering that existed in
the u.s there weren't enough
american-born folks entering those
professions and so my parents and their
friends
coming to america having that
opportunity to tackle the american dream
because of that immigration law changing
meant that inevitably you know what they
knew as success were those fields so of
course they're going to push their
children into those uh into those fields
yet i still remember you know the day
that i was supposed to audition for
ucla's film school uh there was a big
snowstorm in new jersey where i grew up
and the trains getting into manhattan
where i had my audition uh were totally
stopped and my dad said get dressed i'm
taking you and i knew that he and my mom
probably would have preferred that i
don't even apply to the theater film
school
also saw that that you know they moved
halfway around the world when they were
in their early 30s and and i knew that
he saw something in me that said i at
least want to know i want you to know
that i'm supporting you enough to take
you to that audition and that meant the
world you know and and it's not
something that i uh certainly don't take
for granted now but the 17 year old
version of you uh it was definitely a
sobering moment at that time what did
your parents think of when you took on a
stage name you anglicized your name from
your your actual name that you're born
with in part because it helped get you
more roles
were they did they understand that or
were they a little hurt by that
no i think you know the practical thing
about immigrants is they're going to do
they're going to tell you to do whatever
you got to do to make it right and in my
case that having a screen name came out
of a kind of a ridiculous conversation
with some college friends at two in the
morning when i was at ucla and they said
you know what about a screen name
consider screen name you know whoopi
goldberg her name is not whoopi goldberg
it's karen johnson i said well i didn't
know that then i started thinking about
it i said okay of course her name's not
poppy goldberg and they said uh you know
could you imagine if she went by karen
johnson it just wouldn't be as memorable
so around that time i was getting new
headshots as an actor i was still
looking for an agent to represent me i
changed the name on the on the new
headshots uh and within a couple of
months i did have an agent who expressed
interest a wonderful woman named barbara
who took a chance with me and the
conversation with the parents was really
just well if you're playing characters
for your life i mean you do what you got
to do to get in the door i think maybe
it would have been different if i had
legally changed my name it might have
been different their background was a
little different but they were very
practical about if you're pursuing
something that the odds are really
against you kind of do what you got to
do business wise to to open that door i
love that if you were starting all over
today would you take on a stage name or
would you use your real name well you
know what's so wonderful about how much
the industry has changed in the last 20
years is that's almost a an irrelevant
conversation now right and i would
credit a lot of the streamers frankly
you know the netflix's and hulu's and
amazons of the world the type of content
that they're creating is content that
you never would have seen 15 or 20 years
ago so it wouldn't have probably even
been a conversation today where i could
have maybe focused a little more on the
things that i love about the business of
the arts uh rather than focusing on some
of the externalities and that's kind of
a wonderful sign of progress yeah and
you'd have a lot more vowels in your
name as well how has your thinking on
representation evolved i mean you took
the role of a teenage terrorist in 24
because it allowed you to do new things
like like blow things up for instance do
you have any regrets about that now
no i think look what the the nice thing
about how much the industry has changed
and i wouldn't i would i would say this
goes well beyond just hollywood but if
you look at our politics or the changing
nature of even activism or business
things are stronger now because of that
aspect of diversity and of course
there's a value of diversity for the
sake of diversity and it it's nice to
have representation and it certainly
makes the 14 year old version of a kid
like me who never saw himself on screen
feel like you have boundless possibility
but it also makes tremendous business
sense the world is changing the types of
markets that businesses are trying to
enter into this obviously goes for media
and streamers especially but overall you
know it's it's much more diverse the
purchasing power of groups that 15 or 20
years ago you never would have even
thought of i remember interning at a
production company i tell the story in
the book but interning at a production
company and having a boss say why are
you bringing me asian names for actors
for my movie asians don't watch movies
and i looked up the studio
at the time and there was an asterisk
next to asian americans now that
asterisk was not because we collectively
don't see movies it was because nobody
was asking asian americans what kinds of
movies they see to begin with and now
that those questions are being asked we
see that asian americans on a whole are
on par with white americans in terms of
their purchasing power right obviously
that's once you disaggregate that the
data looks a little bit different here
and there but those are the things that
we're dealing with now where i think
businesses and the business community
realizes what a value it is and what a
missed opportunity it would be to not
lean into diversity of content for the
sake of business and also just for the
sake of it being the right thing to do
yeah yeah although the profit motive is
a big driver for that i want to turn out
cal to politics because outside of
acting you do use your real name so you
were a cal pen suresh modi when you
worked at the obama white house and when
you campaigned for him uh to become
president
how did that was that the goal to to
work at the white house after you began
campaigning for him is that what you
envisioned
it wasn't the goal and and fun fact for
those of you who are tracking the name
when you go through your fbi background
check you got to use your legal name
uh but i did have to tell them that i uh
acted in some stronger movies as part of
the background check and they seemed
okay with that um but no look the the uh
the goal was never to work at the white
house i joined the obama campaign when
uh you know he was i think something
like 30 points down in the polls coming
out of the summer of 07. i joined that
fall and the idea there was just you
know uh this was one of two candidates
who work wasn't taking federal lobbyist
money i believe the only other one at
the time
was ron paul
and obama aligned a lot with my politics
and my beliefs and initially i just said
i'll help you volunteer for a weekend
i went out to iowa before the caucuses
and and really fell in love with the
types of people that i was seeing the
kinds of conversations that were
happening at a grassroots words level a
lot of it reminded me of stories that my
grandparents had told me a lot of it was
obviously new and and being around a
diverse dynamic group of people that was
not my experience in hollywood um you
know he ends up winning the iowa
caucuses and then i had the chance to go
to 26 other states worked on the arts
policy committee and a number of other
things that that then led to uh an
unlikely job at the white house and at
that point you know
i applied for it online like a dummy uh
not realizing that i should really take
advantage of my networks that's a lesson
learned but coming from the acting world
i really had no idea that um that you
really need to to lean into all of the
relationships you have to make it work
but look at the end of the day having
the chance to work on uh uh outreach
teams uh around the affordable care act
or the repeal of don't ask don't tell or
student loan reform was was incredibly
meaningful and it was a wonderful
sabbatical yeah gotta leverage all the
networks and all the names that you've
collected over your career so asian
americans we know are the fastest
growing minority group um and
politicians are really now starting to
appreciate the voting power of this
group this population what do you think
given what you've seen in your time in
politics um is the biggest misconception
about how this group participates in the
political process
yeah i think by far the biggest
misconception of asian americans
is that they're a monolithic group you
know we all come under this umbrella of
asian americans but really when you
disaggregate what the community is it's
50 plus subgroups numbers of different
languages you know uh you couple uh
japanese american and indian-american
doctors who may have come here post 1965
in the same category as uh
among refugees or folks who you know uh
native hawaiians for instance and so in
order in order to really uh be effective
at outreach to the community you kind of
have to disaggregate the data that's
something that we did when uh i worked
on the white house initiative for asian
americans and pacific islanders in the
in the white house um and the the way of
putting that together i remember you
know i did share this story in one of
the chapters because i didn't fully even
appreciate you know we put something
like that together thinking this is the
right thing for policy it's the right
thing for for americans of of every walk
of life
and then when you put a piece of
legislation like that or sorry piece of
an executive order like that in uh you
know it was a couple of months later
that the bp oil spill in the gulf
happened and there was a lot of focus on
fishing communities as there should have
been but very little focus on vietnamese
americans and how many vietnamese
american fishermen there were who didn't
speak english as their first language
and had the federal government not you
know had president obama not signed this
executive order the federal government
really wouldn't have been able to
release resources uh targeting that
particular community and then again
similar to the diversity conversation we
just had obviously there's a moral
imperative there but there's also an
economic component to it these are
the fishing industry was devastated by
that by that spill in certain
communities and so to be able to fix
that for the moral imperative of taking
care of our fellow americans and for
business reasons um i think the big
misconception to answer your actual
question is it's all one monolithic
umbrella and we know from experience
that it's really not i mean even if you
look at the indian-american community
you're a democrat you've been a democrat
your entire life but there are plenty of
uh indians indian americans who are
republican and and support for instance
donald trump likewise in the vietnamese
american community as well you just
can't uh put it in one bucket or the
other uh going forward cal what's more
likely do you think another harold and
kumar film or you're campaigning for a
president kabul harris
you know what i think what's amazing is
uh we live in a country where both are
possible that is literally the point of
the of the book that i have the chance
to write so it's uh look i i've never
viewed uh my career choices as mutually
exclusive i have the blessing of uh fans
who have been willing to see my movies
and watch me on tv and buy the book and
audiobook and so i i would i would hate
to say one is more likely than the other
i will tell you for a fact that we are
hoping to get another harold and camargo
uh another heroin car movie off the
ground in the next couple of years i
know the whole team has been really busy
on our other projects um i know nobody's
announced their run for the next
election cycle so uh take take that what
you will
wait harold and kumar are going to be
middle-aged men what are they going to
be doing now
well they have to have kids right there
there has to be a kid component to it
but we'll see we're all ears that the uh
the guys who created the franchise john
roberts and hayden schlossberg have been
really busy with their incredible series
cobra kai for netflix
on his own netflix show that he just got
back from they were shooting in new
zealand i've been busy writing this book
and i was on designated survivor for a
couple years so uh i i i hope that we
come up for air in a sense that we can
we can make it soon because we're look
playing kumar kumar is way cooler than
i'll ever be in real life so
i'm fortunate playing harold and kumar
69 when i'm 120 years old if i live
looking forward to that one um there's a
labor shortage right now we talk about
this all the time on bloomberg how there
are more jobs than there are
workers available to fill them do you
see that happening in show business for
for people like you for asian american
actors
i look you ask i think you ask any
performer this goes for for asian
americans certainly but
across the board there there have always
been a plethora of of artists vying for
really just a handful of roles um it was
that was another actual big
misconception in hollywood even within
the industry that especially if you're
looking at network tv and the more
archaic forms of how we tell stories um
you know the the belief that well where
are we going to find actors who are like
this or where are we going to find
diverse writers i remember two seasons
ago i
co-created a show called sunnyside about
uh young immigrants in in queens here in
new york um and it really wasn't
difficult to create the most diverse
writers room in network tv history we
did it by asking and looking you know
asking agents and managers managers
especially you know don't just send us
your most expensive clients who have
been on
shows before send us your new
up-and-comers uh we were looking at
stand-up comics and and people who
hadn't necessarily had their shop before
and they are wonderful and we had an
incredible writer's room because of it
so uh it's one of the things that i i
think the opportunity here is really to
look in places that uh we haven't
traditionally looked as as a as business
folks love that i want to end on
politics here because there are a lot of
young people who feel betrayed by their
elected officials right now what would
you say to them to
encourage them to keep the faith and not
turn cynical
yeah it's it's tough right i mean the
the uh the system is almost
it is designed in a way to make you feel
complacent you know oh gosh well my does
my voice actually matter i'm
disappointed by somebody i'm not getting
100 of what i want those are all
rational feelings i think the real shame
is that we and i am guilty of this
myself you know you said in that nasty
tweet about something political it feels
amazing but it doesn't necessarily move
the needle government operates slowly on
purpose the the first thing i can think
of most recent example my friends are on
mamdani who was uh on a hunger strike
for 15 days outside of de blasio's
office here in new york city um to
convince the city and convince the mayor
to uh serve as guarantors for cab
drivers who were in debt
that had been driven to suicide because
of that debt i mean the city was really
responsible for orchestrating uh their
situation to begin with and finally
after 15 days the mayor thankfully
relented which we're really thankful for
but i look at somebody like zaron i look
at this uh next generation of leaders
and frankly you can apply this
regardless of anyone's political beliefs
um they're really trying to find the
pressure points that need to exist at
the right time in the right place for
our elected officials to act and
sometimes it's about creating the
political space for them to act and
pressuring them from the outside uh in
ways that they can do their jobs better
yeah good point good point
final question for you have you been
approached to run for office what would
make you consider doing so
i i gotta tell you i love what i do as
an actor first and foremost as a writer
as an artist uh i don't have any
interest to run for office myself but
i'm also very excited to continue to
support people who i believe in and to
to get out on the campaign trail for
them i'd love to have made made no
secret of the fact that you know i'd
love to segue my private sector arts
career into something in the cultural
diplomacy space when i retire maybe an
ambassadorship or something like that
but i don't think that i'd run for
office myself all right we'll look to
add uh ambassador to your list of many
many jobs cal pen by the way
congratulations on your engagement as
well as your partner thank you i
appreciate it calpin is an actor and
author of you can't be serious which is